[Musique]
les organisateurs de ce tedx tandis que
vous étiez un public bienveillant et
très ouvert alors je vois su dire et
c'est peut-être l'occasion justement de
de libérer encore un peu plus c'est
c'est bien veillant ce que vous avez
dans le coeur et je me suis dit qu'on
pourrait introduire ce talk par un petit
exercice et si vous êtes d'accord
je vous invite simplement vous allez
voir comme c'est très simple en fait à
libérer cette bienveillance parce qu'on
l'a naturellement nous et je vous
propose pendant un moment pendant
quelques minutes de fermer les yeux et
vous avez simplement maintenant penser
un petit enfant qui viennent de naître
alors si vous êtes déjà parents vous
avez certainement assister à la
naissance d'un enfant et 6 et paca vous
pouvez bien sûr facilement l'imaginer et
je vous propose vingt ans maintenant de
fermer les yeux et de penser ce petit
enfant qui viennent d'être cet enfant
est vulnérable et il va avoir besoin
pour parcourir sa vie pour traverser les
différentes étapes de sa vie il va avoir
besoin de l'amour de ses parents et en
ce moment même vous pouvez laisser
émaner de vous même de votre coeur
ce sentiment de bienveillance à l'égard
de ce petit enfant qui a besoin de cet
amour et vous pouvez voir comment vous
même vous pouvez vous sortir simplement
en laissant s'exprimer tout simplement
votre amour
voilà et puisqu'on parle d'enfants je
vais vous raconter l'histoire d'un petit
enfant qui est né dans une famille
ouvrière au milieu de six autres enfants
et il vit une sorte de roman de zola sa
vie est assez difficile parce que ses
parents sans grande difficulté et
souvent se réfugie dans l'alcool pour
essayer d anesthésier leurs souffrances
sa mère qui est en grande souffrance
aussi passent beaucoup de temps à
essayer de mourir alors c'est évidemment
c'est très insécurisant pour cet enfant
mais le pire pour cette enfance et qu'
il est régulièrement battu par ses
professeurs
c'est dans les années 70 l'éducation
parfois dans certains villages et très
dur très strictes et vit quelque chose
de très difficile il a la peur au ventre
chaque fois qui doit aller à l'école et
surtout il lui arrive un drame c'est que
à l'âge de 8 ans il a un accident grave
qui à faire que il va être en retard
d'un trimestre à l'école ce qui va lui
valoir d'être encore plus souvent battu
parce qu'ils n'entrent fesseur assis
tyrannique qui avait inventé une une
espèce de punition pour ceux qui
savaient pas répondre aux questions et
qui consistait il appelait ça la danse
de l'ours et demande l enfant devenir
sur l'estrade il le souhaitait à tuyaux
de kun a tué avec un tuyau de gaz
cette vie ce petit enfant à l'âge de 13
ans se trouve dans le salon de la maison
et son oncle en le voyant pas ce qu'il
est en train de dessiner en le voyant 30
dessinée parce que c'était un moyen de
se réfugier de fuir la souffrance aussi
son oncle voyons dessiné lui dit qu'est
ce que tu veux faire plus tard et
l'enfant se redresse et lui dit je veux
être heureux et l'oncle très surpris par
cette réponse lui mais c'est pas un
métier ça lui dit mais qu'est ce que ça
peut me faire d'avoir un métier si je
suis pas heureux papa maman boivent en
cachette maman passe son temps à vouloir
mourir
et pourtant les pas heureuse
les professeurs à l'école nous battent
ils ont un métier ils ne sont pas
heureux
alors à quoi bon avoir un métier cet
enfant s'appelle bruno et c'était moi
la question du bonheur s'est posé très
vite à moi et je voulais comprendre
je voulais comprendre évidemment le sens
de la souffrance et le sens de la bonne
heure du bonheur parce que je me disais
que la vie était certainement en train
de me faire une ville est une farce ou
alors ça n'avait pas beaucoup de sens de
vivre à 15 ans j'avais parcouru tous les
livres de raymond moody vous en avez
peut-être entendu parler qui parle de la
vie après la vie et j'ai eu une première
réponse dans nos existences
j'ai vécu une expérience qui a
complètement bouleversé ma vie j'avais
complètement raté mes études et je
travaillais à ce moment là j'avais 19
ans et avec mon salaire je me suis
offert un stage pour apprendre à parler
au public
non pas que je voulais apprendre à
parler en public c'est surtout que en
fait je voulais sortir de ma timidité
les sorties du stage était très fatigué
il me restait encore un petit peu de
vacances et j'ai pris le premier train
pour aller dans le sud parce que j'avais
envie de me détendre
j'ai roulé de nuit je suis arrivé le
matin 7h30
il faisait encore un petit peu frais et
puis j'ai pas voulu chercher un endroit
tout de suite pour dormir
j'ai voulu aller sur la plage sur la
plage d'antibes où je me suis allongé
j'ai étiré la serviette de mon sac et je
me suis mis en maillot de bain malgré le
fait qu'il faisait encore un peu frais
et là je ne savais pas ce qui
m'attendait je me suis allongé sur ses
plages et s'est passé quelque chose
d'étrange c'est que d'abord mon corps
s'est mis à se détendre très
profondément sens que je fasse quoi que
ce soit c'était plutôt agréable
rien d'extraordinaire jusque là mais
ensuite ce qui s'est passé est assez
extraordinaire c'est que comme dans une
expérience de proximité de la mort j'ai
vu toute ma vie défiler à une vitesse
extraordinaire et je me rappelais des
pans entiers de mon existence de ma
toute petite enfance avec une précision
d'horloger
j'ai assisté en spectateurs à ce
phénomène qui était assez extraordinaire
et ça défile ça défile et à une vitesse
extraordinaire et un moment tout s'est
arrêté
contrairement aux expériences de
proximité de la mort je n'ai pas vu
le tunnel de lumière mais je me suis
retrouvé dans un état de très grande
plénitude
un bonheur intense comme je n'en avais
je n'en avais jamais vécu en fait la vie
était en train de de répondre à ces
grandes questions est ce qu'on peut être
heureux et je sentais ce une impression
s'était même pas une impression je me
sentais unifiée totalement et je suis
resté ainsi jusqu'à 15h30 environ de
l'après midi je ne vais pas bougé le
petit doigt tellement c'était délicieux
je voulais pas sortir de de sept états
s'étaient tellement tellement bon et
vers 15h30
je me suis assise et j'ai regardé autour
de moi et je coûte je voyais bien sûr
comme on le fait tous je regardais le
monde et je continue à voir le monde par
l'intermédiaire de mes sens mais à une
différence près c'est que ce sentiment
d'unité était toujours là et quand je
regardais les personnes autour de moi je
me sentais complètement lié en fait
c'est même pas que je me sentais liée
c'est que je me voyais lit et je voyais
je regardais la mouette dans le ciel et
j'étais lié à cette mouette et je
réalisais que comme disent les
physiciens quantiques mais sauf que là
c'était une expérience il n'y a pas de
séparation réelle entre les objets de
nos perceptions à 15h30 je me suis levé
toujours dans cet état de parfaite unité
de bonheur total
et j'ai pris une direction sans trop
savoir où j'allais chez simplement
marcher et je suis arrivé devant un
terrain de camping et j'arrive à
l'accueil et jeudi à la personne côté
j'aimerais bien une c'était les premiers
mots que je prononçais de la journée
jeudi écoutez j'aimerais avoir une une
place mais j'ai un petit soucis je n'ai
pas de toiles de tentes
il avait encore le téléphone à la main
ils me disent passe quelque chose de
bizarre j'ai vu ah bon il me dit une
personne qui est parti ce matin qui
vient de m'appeler
et il m'a dit écoutez j'ai oublié ma
toile de tente mais je suis beaucoup
trop loin pour la pour venir la chercher
vous la donnerai la première personne
qui arrive et c'était moi j'ai vécu une
expérience aussi tout aussi étrange
pendant ma nuit puisque j'ai j'ai fait
ma première nuit en pleine conscience
le lendemain j'étais toujours un peu
dans cet état mais ça commençaient à
s'amenuiser au mental a commencé à
s'interroger à se poser de toutes sortes
de questions et la maquette est devenu
extrêmement active je voulais comprendre
ce qui m'était arrivé je suis mais est
ce que ça peut arriver à tout le monde
est ce qu'on peut vivre tous ce genre de
choses et qu'est ce qui met vraiment
arrivé et là mon mental est devenu
extrêmement actif
j'avale et des livres sur la
spiritualité sur la psychologie sûr il
fallait que je comprenne mais il était
temps pour moi de rentrer et là j'ai
vécu une nouvelle expérience
d'expérience de retour qui était assez
douloureuse parce que je suis retourné à
mon entreprise et là c'était assez
difficile les machines me faisait très
mal aux oreilles le bruit des gens je me
sentais complètement décalé entre ce que
je venais de vivre cette paix profonde
essai de vie agitée stressante et je ne
me reconnaissais plus de tous deux ans
et moi qui était promu à un bel avenir
dans cette entreprise puisque aux
patrons souhaitait que je devienne
ingénieurs j'ai commis erreur sur erreur
et à tel point que mon patron a fini par
me congédier et en même temps ma petite
amie aussi avec mes parents ça devenait
difficile et je me suis retrouvé à la
rue
je suis allé en foyer de jeunes
travailleurs pendant plusieurs mois j'ai
mes compagnons d'infortuné tu es souvent
des drogués des alcooliques je ne
touchais pas la drogue je voulais pas et
je me suis fait assez souvent agressés
et je me suis dit je ne peux pas rester
là il faut que je parte il me restait
toujours tout juste cinquante francs
puisqu'à l'époque c'était des francs et
avec 6 50 francs j'ai pris un billet
pour paris
sans savoir trop ce que j'allais faire
là bas mais il fallait que je parte et
quand je suis arrivé à paris
j'étais accompagné de mon angoisse qui
ne me lâchait pas parce que j'avais du
mal de me projeter dans l'avenir et je
suis allé au sacré coeur où j'ai fait
une grande prière moi qui priaient
jamais j'ai fait une grande prière pour
demander de l'aide malheureusement je
suis sorti comme chez entré et il me
restait encore quelques centimes jusqu'à
l'époque avec quelques centimes on
pouvait encore se payer un café et je me
suis offert un café si le café
je crois que j'ai mis le plus de temps à
boire et à ce moment là il ya des jeunes
à peu près de mon âge voire un peu plus
ce qu'ils sont entrés dans le café et
qui discuter et puis ils ont fini par me
mêler à leur conversation et on a
échangé je n'ai pas voulu leur parler de
ma situation je n'en avais pas le coeur
est et on a fini par sympathiser là il
ya eu un courant vraiment qu'il s'est
installée entre nous et il s'apprêtait à
partir le soir étaient venus et m'ont
dit comme ça mais coûte situe là rien de
prévu ce soir nous on a une petite
soirée tu peux venir avec nous et je le
redis et va écouter non j'ai rien de
prévu
donc je veux bien vous accompagner et on
a passé toute la soirée et vers 3 heures
du matin il m'a proposé de me ramener et
là je leur ai parlé de ma situation et
monde écoute on va pas te laisser comme
ça tu viens avec nous et j'ai fait
partie de leurs troupes
g et m'ont appris à faire du théâtre de
rue et en faisant du théâtre de rue j'ai
pu payer mes études de psychologie
j'ai étudié je voulais comprendre
justement ce qui à la fois ce qui m'est
arrivé c'était je n'étais pas destiné à
devenir psychologue et je voulais juste
avoir des réponses
mais je reste un petit peu sur ma faim
ensuite j'ai quitté mes amis je voulais
passer du temps seul donc j'ai parcouru
la france avec mon baluchon et j'ai
consacré beaucoup de temps à la
méditation
ensuite je suis rentré j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un j'ai fini par me retrouver à
strasbourg
et là j'ai on a un petit peu forcé la
main mais je me suis retrouvé avec un
cabinet j'ai accompagné des gens et ça
faisait à peu près un an que j'exerçais
et j'ai fait une deuxième grande
expérience dans ma vie qui a donné
réponse j'ai rencontré un grand sage
tibétain du nom de chimie loading mbochi
et il était la réponse que je cherchais
cet homme il était comme disait matthieu
ricard
il n'y avait pas de de décalage entre le
message est le messager
cet homme était on l'appelait la force
tranquille la force immobile et je ne
l'est plus quittés pendant 15 ans ça a
été un changement très profond dans ma
vie j'ai trouvé la paix j'ai retrouvé
beaucoup de questions ont trouvé réponse
et puis une autre expérience aussi est
arrivé je me promenais dans ça faisait
15 ans que je fréquente et chimie rhodia
mme boucher je me promenais dans mon
village avec une amie et il ya eu des
lucioles qui sont apparues mais quand je
dis des lucioles c'était des milliers
des milliards de lucioles on avait
l'impression d'être dans un conte de
fées du second ami mais tu vois ça aux
citoyens mais des oui mais c'est
incroyable qu'est ce qui se passe on
avait l'impression d'être dans un conte
de fées et on rentre dans la maison ça
dégouline est le long des fenêtres y
avait des flux lucioles absolument
partout je comprenais pas ce qui se
passait et le lendemain la personne qui
m'a permis de rencontrer chimie de
résine coach et me dit que il faut que
je t'annonce quelque chose rimpoché
décédé et ça correspondait exactement
avec l'apparition des lucioles
plus tard j'ai rencontré un autre lama
tibétain qui m'a dit il tu as fait un
magnifique cadeau ce que tu réalises les
lucioles c'est la lumière dans la nuit
je suis madrilien bocce m'a dit un jour
l'homme c'est comme une voiture à deux
moteurs
il ya un moteur qui pousse en avant ce
sont nos aspirations positive il ya un
moteur qui tire en arrière ce sont nos
peurs nos vues fausse nos préjugés et
toutes ces émotions négatives qui
viennent trahir cette paix intérieure et
aujourd'hui le thème ses perspectives et
ça m'a fait penser tout de suite à une
citation du bouddha qu'ils disent est ce
que vous êtes aujourd'hui dépend de ce
que vous avez fait hier et demain dépend
de ce que vous faites aujourd'hui on
accorde beaucoup d'importance au passé
et à l'avenir et on oublie que notre
avenir se construit maintenant est un
des principaux ingrédients du bonheur
que nous cherchons tous c'est l'amour
altruiste
j'ai envie de vous dire vous êtes tous
des lucioles dans la nuit vous êtes tous
des lumières dans la nuit merci
d'exister
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]